robbie this is an historic day for japan
what is the relationship the linkage of
the japanese people to their Emperor
well this is not an economic issue but I
think that the Emperor is very very
widely respected here he's been an
excellent Emperor he as he probably know
from his early days on he had an
American super an early post-war period
who wrote a beautiful book about about
him and about the experience and if the
windows for the Crown Prince it's a book
i would recommend people week because it
gives a very strong sense of how much
what's the right word affection people
have had for him the affection for the
family is i would suggest radically
different than what we see in the united
kingdom compare and contrast the
solitude of the royal family in Japan
versus what we see in the Western world
I think he was upon the notion of the
Emperor as a symbol of the state is very
important it's something that people
consider part of their identity is part
of the body politic and that is one
thing that I think has helped give
people a sense of identity for their
country and help them stick together in
difficult times like the earthquake a
few years ago or the economic
difficulties that we had so I think that
in offense the imperial family has
played a and the world of society has
given them is a key element in the
cohesiveness of the society here so for
the economy economic point of view it's
been a good thing for us to maintain
social cohesion right has he I mean this
is a ceremonial right he's the head of
state for Japan's constitutional
monarchy but this is a ceremonial role
has he ever talked about affairs of
state the the monarch here in the UK of
course Queen Elizabeth the second is
very removed or she will never
politicize anything but we also have
ceremonial rolls around the world
including it city that have stepped in
when times get tough that has not
happened in Japan isn't it is not the
Emperor's role under the Constitution to
do that and the Imperial Household
agency in the Emperor himself has been
very very careful to have immense
respect for the Constitution
and the role it provides him Robbie will
come back to you and our guests here in
New York on the Japanese economy but
tell us about the lineage of the Emperor
in the view forward for the family
obviously the succession is very clear
they're very explicit laws about the
session there are people in the rolls
now and so there is no really no
uncertainty about the succession ok so
what people can rest assured that that
its accession long is very solid